et maintenant ma femme et moi j'en ai
pas il le chante ma joie marque de sous
vêtements
ouais si marina foïs et f1
vt
ouais bravo marine marine high tech
voilà vous connaissez à la main à la
main le petit protégé de le principe
protégés de pascal sevran
pascal voulez mais parce qu'elle sevran
peuvent à mais je connais pas bien mais
je vois j'aime bien le personnage parce
que c'est quelqu'un qui dit ce qu'il
pense
ouais voilà donc j'aime bien les gens
qui disent qu'ils pensent pouvoir alors
qu'il est ici ce soir info rens
vous êtes ici ce soir vous êtes ici ce
soir pour un livre signé par les robins
des bois qui s'appelle l'histoire de
france 2 avant a maintenant chez canal+
édition marinard china une des seules
femmes enceintes alcoolique crie ça se
ressent
le
c'est la chanteuse préférée après janis
joplin a l'air de faire l'apologie de
l'apologie du l'alcoolisme pour réussir
pour la chaîne arte
en fait c'était bruno gaccio dis moi
c'est le seul moyen que tu as trouvé
pour avoir de grosses pincettes tomber
en simple oui alors bon puisqu'on parle
de mes seins tout de suite je suis
contente oui font même pas tellement
vrai si vous voulez la vérité ils ont
pas tellement grossi ces dessins vous
avez touché
non mais je peux toucher mais frappé
dans le rsa peut être vulgaire mais
comme c'est une vieille amie ch
et alors eh ben c'est dur de dire que
moi il y en a plus c'est dur c'est
normal finalement tu as des jolies
chaussures merci alors là c'est les
précédents comment tu te souviens encore
le marina est ce que désormais vous vous
sentez plus femme au fond de vous ouais
je crois que rosemère c'est le plus beau
jour de ma vie
est ce que le regard des hommes a changé
sur vous marina ouais alors alors je
voudrais annoncer aux filles si vous
comptez vous faire draguer quand vous
êtes un simple c'est loupé ah bon eh
ouais ça marche plus du tout pas du tout
mais dit faisait draguer quand tu étais
enceinte tu as raison maintenant vous
avez les dessins vous vous sentez plus
proche de rechuter plus du tout ouais à
bien vous pensez que les robins savez
que vous y avoir un enfant marina bay je
leur ai demandé l'autorisation bien sûr
ainsi qu'un rapport sexuel à chacun et
je ne sais plus qui a gagné ah bon on va
vite le voir un si petit et chauvin vous
pensez qu'il s'en rendrait compte que
vous étiez une femme qui désiraient
avoir un enfant non parce que c'est vrai
qu'ils m'ont toujours vu comme un auteur
et f
au nom aussi attention ça est sur tes
sens et je n'ai jamais les plus gros que
marina ont pu tuer donc oui ronsin oui
c'est vrai que marc par rapport à mes
seins si j'ai décidé de pas faire
d'enfant c'était pour qu'ils restent
tels que c'est parce qu'il veut dire tel
quel ou tu as eu coup alors j'ai dit ok
donc vous êtes ici ce soit pour la lutte
d'histoires drôles dans un livre eux
disent non un livre d'histoire avec un
grand h une histoire de la france dont
notre joli pays aux mille fromages
virgule livre qui est drôle pareil si
vous utilisez très peu de mots un
mouvement comprend pas le sens de ce que
vous dites est ce que voulait bien nous
en détail et du contenu
est ce que vous voulez bien maison
détaillé oui je prenais une inspire
avant de parler c'est normal voilà
écoutez ça s'appelle déjà
l'histoire de france 2 avant maintenant
c'est un livre assez exhaustif sur donc
tout ce qui s'est passé dans notre pays
depuis qu'il existe
c'est la ligne éditoriale c'est vraiment
un souci de vérité
en gros tout est vrai à part les faits
et les dates
c'est un livre qui est destiné à toutes
les personnes qui désirent perpétuer
leur ignorance
c'est à dire une robin des bois par
exemple de faire 6 6 livres achetés ça
va aller ça va pas mal écoute
le bec sur le port d'amsterdam avait
apporté une sterne non je peux pas je
peux pas faire ça fait foi parce que
parce que c'est si atroce parce que j'ai
pas le costume pour chanter amsterdam
aussi les deux dealers de shit mais moi
j'ai jamais pour dc est ce que c'est
vrai marina que alain decaux a voulu
vous casser la gueule à pour avoir du
jeu ouais mais c'est moi qui vais péter
les gens vous suivez alani suite
ahmed suite à m